there is new royalty on Twitch someone
has risen to the top to be the most
subscribed to English speaking streamer
and his exponential rise is something
astonishing his name is Kai sanat and if
you don't know his name you better learn
it
[Music]
hey guys before I get into the video a
huge thank you and shout out to Elgato
our friends gave me this beautiful brand
new XLR microphone and also of course
the goodies that you've seen before so a
huge thank you and shout out to them so
recently you might have seen some news
of some breaking 80 000 subscribers on
Twitch or maybe you saw it when they hit
90 000 or maybe it was when they hit 100
000 subscribers or maybe it was when he
broke his own hype train record the
whole time record shattered you reach
new levels of support wait I said that
oh my God if you haven't heard of the
newest Titan of twitch please allow me
to introduce Kai snat whose Clips I
would have played more of but they all
have copyrighted music in them so
originally Kai posted his content
including comedy skits on platforms like
Instagram and Facebook yo bro wake up
Kai then joined YouTube in 2018 with
this first video people that don't know
me I am an actor slash Entertainer slash
comedian slash whatever you want to call
me I I am black and I'm saying something
you got that silky silky silky ass skin
downstairs
important things
just call me okay since then he's posted
a variety of content including pranks
and challenges in August of 2020 Kai
joined the content group amp which
stands for any means possible where they
do similar variety style content but
look at his statistics will show you
that he's had some pretty city growth
but around July 2021 is when things
really began to take off for him between
August and September of that year is
when he hit 1 million subscribers he
reacted live to him hitting 1 million
subscribers and he was equal parts
emotional and grateful for the milestone
to be in the shelter in Georgia and now
I'm in the
big ass house in Georgia this a few
years later bro a few years later boom
it's about what I couldn't afford Kaya's
growth can be attributed to a lot of
different things his willingness to
produce quality content on a regular
basis maybe one of them but if you look
at all the kinds of videos he makes
they're fun current exciting and
something everyone can relate to whether
it be dealing with relationships
laughing at pranks participating in
challenges or even more Vlog style
content Kai produces content that while
might not be completely new to the
YouTube sphere is still refreshing to
see Kai is genuine funny and creative as
his Reddit common explains for someone
who asks about his rise to start he
became popular with Aiden who became
popular because of Ronnie and they share
a ton of the same audience he knows
actual famous people easy Community to
get into and understand try as hard to
make good content streams consistently
the number one reason though is the
e-dates they did he's always really
funny in them and they got like 100k
viewers each what the comment is
alluding to is the W Community as study
Court explains the W Community is a
loose connection of streamers who
largely emerged on Twitch around the
same time and share many of the same
audience members streamers who identify
as members of this group include the
likes of Aiden Ross your rage Kai
sanatiana and more sharing my audience
will get you far considering how popular
people like Gideon and Aiden Ross are
not to diminish any of Kai's hard work
the time of recording this video he has
2.75 million subscribers on YouTube over
700 000 followers on Twitter and 1.8
million followers on Instagram but this
year especially Kai has gained a lot of
Fame from his streaming on Twitch in
fact in some ways you can say it has
eclipsed his YouTube success as far as I
can tell Kai first started streaming on
Twitch early 2021 similar to his YouTube
Kai had really steady growth while
streaming in a variety of categories
including just chatting Fall Guys
fortnite Uncharted 4. but like his
YouTube he experienced a burst of growth
in late June 2022. also huge shout out
to Kai for playing Beyond Two Souls I
feel like people forgot about that game
and I think it deserves more of Kai is
now the number two most subscribed to
streamer on Twitch and with 2.3 million
followers he is not going anywhere soon
unfortunately his rise on the platform
has not been without some controversy in
fact some people have been suspicious of
his growth last month there was some
speculation on the live stream fail
subreddit that he was laundering money
the wild idea is that one or many people
would buy Kai's Subs with illegal or
dirty money and then Kyle let's send
back the clean money to them some of you
guys might remember the scandal in
turkey with twitch and money laundering
in May 18 people were arrested as a part
of a money loan during the scheme where
scammers would send twitch streamers
bits paid with stolen credit cards in
exchange for Clean Cash that's a huge
commission fee to Twitch for laundry
money you would lose 50 immediately huh
foreign
[Music]
or is he defending me might as well just
buy crypto right someone check my
laundering scheme I don't know know how
this works now I know people on the
internet can post whatever they want but
that insane speculation is so weird to
me like Kai is celebrating this insane
Milestone why is that the first thing
your mind goes to people are quick to
point out that when other white content
creators hit large Milestones no such
accusations were levied but when a black
content creator like Kai hits the
Milestone it is met with accusations to
try and delegitimize their success when
Kai hit 60k Subs Osmond gold
called.twitch for not recognizing his
achievement various other streamers
essentially said that it was because of
favoritism on twitch's end that they
have their favorite creators and that is
who they stick by while otk founder tips
out said because companies only pretend
to care about black people when it fits
their agenda Kai himself has also called
twitch out for their lack of action and
supporting black creators twitch I need
y'all to be watching what's going on
Twitch
I gotta understand bro
you feel me for so many years for all
people of my color hasn't been doing bro
we've been unrecognizable and I refuse I
will be going to twitchcon and I better
get your boat
I'm telling you right now I refuse for
my community to go unnoticed there has
been a movement known as the hashtag
twitch do better movement where twitch
has been called on to treat black
creators equitably Kai was eventually
acknowledged by Twitch in a tweet but
without acknowledging his achievements
on the platform so twitch won't say it I
will Kai snot is the second most
subscribed to streamer on Twitch and the
number one English speaking subscribe to
streamer on Twitch and at the very least
somebody should keep your eye on Kai has
discussed his upbringing how he grew up
in the shelter with his mom Kai said
that his mother is the person that
always gave him motivation which makes
months like this upcoming clip all the
more meaningful they look so proud of
you even number one
and I'm so happy to be your mom
know that you've been working hard like
this for a long time
he's a grinder every day every state and
and he gives me the world and I want the
world
okay yeah I love you too
hyacin immense growth rapidly and
frankly it is really inspiring to see so
here's to you Kai may your platform
flourish and your successes be many
here's my hot take of the day everyone
Uncharted 4 not the best in charge again
second Uncharted the best Uncharted game
fight me in my DMs fight me in the
comments section if you come in here
telling me it's the third one
I need you to replay that game I just
need you to replay and think about it
okay just do that for me